A base de popopop up
Je voulais vous faire une vidéo sur Périscope car ces derniers temps il y a pas mal
de choses
qui se passent sur l'appli qui sont assez
tristes.
Le plus triste c'etait  il y a deux
jours quand une fille s'est donné la
mort
mais avant ça il y eu même des jeunes qui disaient "voilà au bout de 50
personnes qui se connectent à
l'application
on se met à frapper des gens dans la
rue", donc y'a un mec qui s'est fait taper
à Bordeaux, je crois.
Sinon, il y a eu des employés de SFR qui ont dit. Deux employés qui étaient là
à dire
Si il y a tant de personne en bousille ce téléphone là. Donc
Il y a pas mal de choses qui se passent
sur l'application et donc j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi.
Pourquoi il y a ces trucs-là.
je pense que.. Dans toute cette vidéo là, je vais pas faire
ma réflexion par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé il y a deux jours, car je considère que c'est un cas
à part, parce que c'est un cas plus grave.
Je vais plus m'intéresser aux
délinquants quoi, un petit peu.
Donc les mecs de SFR ou les mecs qui ont frappé
d'autres gens dans la rue
et je pense que ce qui est recherché, en
tout cas ce qui a l'air d'être recherché
c'est un peu l'audience, tu vois. Quand on dit "à partir de tant de personnes, je fais ci"
ou j'ai même vu des trucs genre "à partir de tant de
personnes je montre mes seins" etc...
Il y a une recherche d'audience, enfin je
sais pas si c'est ce qu'on recherche en
tout cas tout se passe comme si
on cherchait ça. Ok ?
J'aimerais comprendre pourquoi.
Pourquoi on recherche l'audience ?
Je pense qu'on a vu ensemble avec la
vidéo sur Hegel  (Si vous ne l'avez pas vu, je vous la mets là)
que finalement, la reconnaissance de l'autre, ou en tout cas le fait
que l'autre
nous voit
ça nous rapporte à notre propre existence.
Donc c'est une manière de se sentir
exister.
Il y a ça, et aussi la célébrité. Je
pense que le mode de vie des
célébrités se voit, et ça peut donner envie.
Et puis même on peut vouloir passer à la télé, à la radio etc...
Ce n'est pas pour rien que l'on utilise le mot "percer", par exemple.
Quand on dit  vous "t'as percé".
C'est comme si il y avait une sorte de
plafond invisible et qu'on arrivait à
passer au travers ça.
Donc c'est une forme, en fait, de
réussite
dans le langage en tout cas.
Donc c'est peut être
ce qui est recherché aussi. Et vu qu'en plus, ça a l'air de plus en plus
accessible, parce que les gens qui sont
célèbres
sont un peu comme vous et moi, de plus en plus on se sent proche
d'eux.
Notamment avec des outils comme Périscope etc..
Snapchat et Cie.
Vu qu'on se sent proche d'eux, on se dit pourquoi pas. Peut être que
ça peut les attirer plus
et en plus ce qu'il y a derrière, la volonté
suprême
je pense ce qui se cache là, c'est celle
de l'immortalité.
c'est celle de
passer dans l'histoire quoi !
C'est un peu comme Érostrate qui
avait brûlé le temple d'Artémis,
à Éphèse,
qui est une merveille du monde antique et
quand on lui a demandé pourquoi il l'a
fait, c'était pour la
célébrité.
Il l'a clairement dit. Après je pense
que c'est pas la seule raison
qui peut pousser à faire de la merde
sur Périscope. Je pense que parfois c'est
juste un prétexte.
C'est comme quand tu t'embrouilles avec un gars dans la rue
il ya des gars qui sont frappés
jusqu'à parce que il l'a mal regardé.
C'est genre "Ouais je lui ai donné une droite, il m'a
mal regardé."
Non, en fait tu avais juste envie de
le frapper.
Et tu as pris comme prétexte le fait
que le mec t'as mal regardé. Soit.
C'est plus une recherche de prétexte qu'une
motivation en soi.
Alors du coup est-ce que tout ça fait
de Périscope un outil de merde ?
Alors je pense pas. Ça me fait penser à
la vidéo de Jhon Rachid d'il y a
quelques semaines ou quelques mois.
Qui a fait une vidéo sur Périscope pour dire à quel point c'était naze.
et qu'il y avait aucun
contenus culturels ou intéressants etc...
En fait, c'est FAUX (voix très aigüe :) )
par exemple il y a une semaine ou deux. Il y a une journaliste
qui a fait un live Périscope depuis la
Corée du Nord.
Inédit, incroyable. C'est la première fois que l'on voyait
la Corée du Nord en live sur internet
en tout cas moi c'était la première fois
que je la voyais, et j'étais pas le seul.
La Nuit Debout aussi, genre un mec a fait des Périscopes sur la Nuit Debout qui ont
battu les records en France
d'affluence sur Périscope, c'était dingue.
Même dans une moindre mesure, mes lives Périscopes à moi.
Souvent je fais de la lecture, genre
Schopenhauer  des trucs comme ça.
Où on lit un texte ensemble, et on
l'explique. Et franchement on passe
un bon moment quoi.
Ou alors l'autre fois c'était sur des notions de marketing.
Enfin, moi je trouve ça intéressant.
Périscope c'est qu'un outil, du coup
ça dépend ce qu'on en fait.
Du coup, vu que c'est un outil c'est assez intéressant parce qu'il permet de
révéler certaines choses.
Moi je pense que premièrement et c'est l'un des trucs les plus importants, ça nous permet
de voir qu'il y a un manque d'écoute.
Si tu as des personnes qui se mettent
sur Périscope en recherche d'attention
etc
c'est peut être parce que ces personnes-là elles ne peuvent pas s'exprimer d'une manière plus
simple
et que, finalement ce sont des
personnes qui sont isolées.
Est-ce que ça ne révèle pas un besoin de
célébrité ?  Parce que la célébrité
nous paraît de plus en plus accessible aussi?
Et je trouve intéressant de voir qu'en fait on nourrit notre ennui
par n'importe quoi.
Genre, tu as des mecs qui sont hyper balèzes,
des scénaristes qui te font des séries de ouf
des films de ouf, des albums incroyables avec des putains d'artistes etc...
Et toi tu préfères t'ennuyer sur Périscope.
C'est révélateur d'un truc. Ça te montre à quel point le
voyeurisme
a une place importante
et c'est pas forcément négatif parce que le
voyeurisme
si tu prends le truc à la base, c'est
quand même la curiosité pour les autres.
C'est de la curiosité pour autrui, tu vois.
Moi c'est un peu ça aussi qui me
pousse à essayer de comprendre comment
marche le Monde, comment marchent les Hommes etc...
C'est un peu de ça, tu vois.
Après il y a une manière de faire
évidemment, mais je peux pas blâmer
quelqu'un qui a ce côté voyeuriste.
je peux pas le faire
parce que je l'ai aussi en fait. Mais d'une
manière.
Un autre un problème que Périscope met en avant ce qu'en fait le live
c'est un métier, tu vois. Gérer un live c'est un métier.
Je pense que c'est très facile de se
retrouver devant des gens
de vouloir les divertir et du coup.. "putain faut que je trouve un truc à faire,
un truc immédiat"
et c'est beaucoup plus facile et
immédiat de faire du mal
que de faire du bien.
Donc, je pense que c'est un point qui est critique
dans la gestion de Périscope.
Du coup la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est : est-ce qu'on aurait commis les
mêmes actes
sans Périscope ?
Et je parle pas du suicide, parce que pour
moi c'est beaucoup plus complexe.
Je parle des autres actes dont je vous ai parlé vite fait.
Donc est-ce qu'on aurait commis ces
actes sans Périscope ?
Et si la réponse est non.
Est-ce que Périscope
est responsable ?
Et bah en fait, pour moi Périscope
n'est pas responsable
Si tu veux,
c'est Périscope, n'importe qui peut y aller. C'est le principe.
C'est comme si t'avais un village
et que tu mettais une scène au milieu.
Et genre n'importe qui peut
monter sur la scène, il y a différentes
scènes pour qu'on puisse le faire même
temps etc...
et donc les gens passent, s’arrêtent et regardent.
Si un mec fait de la merde
tu vas pas en vouloir
à la scène. Tu vois ce que je veux dire, ça n'a pas de sens. Érostrate
pour faire son incendie, il n'a pas eu
besoin de Périscope.
Il y a des choses qui sont incroyables à faire avec Périscope.
Oui, effectivement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas trop de culture. Il n'y a pas de trop de
divertissement de qualité pour l'instant sur Periscope parce que c'est le début.
C'est une plate-forme qui vient de se
créer et ça met du temps à
mûrir. C'est comme sur youtube,
plus on avance dans le temps et plus on
a des trucs hyper niche, hyper pointus.
Il ya des chaînes de vulgarisations de trucs.. Genre, il y a des chaînes
de zététique par exemple.
Il y a un haut niveau.
Je voulais quand même vous exprimer ça
parce que dans les
médias il y a très peu de défenseurs, un petit peu,
de l'application. Alors que moi je pense que
c'est un truc incroyable il y a tellement
de choses à faire avec.
C'est un superbe outil.
et comme tous les outils que l'on met  aux mains de l'humanité
il y a des trucs qui sont
dégueulasses avec.
Mais ce n'est pas de la faute
de l'outil. Encore une fois c'est juste
que ça révèle des choses sur nous
sur notre humanité.
Ça révèle des problèmes que l'on a pas forcément envie de voir
en rapport avec notre nature.
Je pense que vous avez compris mon point.
C'était juste une petite vidéo
très rapide
de réflexion à voix haute. Parce que ça m'a fait travailler un petit peu
cette histoire.
Du coup je vais résumer en un seul Tweet : "Périscope n'est que ce que l'on en
fait.
Il révèle des caractères propres à
nous.
Il rend une forme de faiblesse plus
facile et visible."
Merci d'avoir regardé, n'hésitez pas à
donner vos théories, vos impressions, ce
que vous vous pensez dans les commentaires.
Je suis sûr qu'il y a des gens qui pensent que par exemple
Périscope est responsable. Donc
N'hésitez pas à donner vos arguments
et à expliquer pourquoi etc..
Et voilà !
On se revoit bientôt. Je dois bosser sur un Coup de Phil'
mais j'avais envie de faire cette vidéo
donc voilà. Je me remets sur le Coup de Phil'
Ciao !